there's nothing more delicious than the
truth served cold to someone feasting on
a diet of lies here's ted koppel telling
our nation's hall monitor brian Stelter
what we already knew Donald Trump has
been very very good for baseball
he has been wonderful for the industry
if readings are up that means what that
oh the ratings are up it means you can't
do without Donald Trump you would be
lost without Donald Trump it's not true
CNN's ratings would be in the toilet
without Donald Trump
wow I haven't seen Stelter that
defensive since Anderson Cooper stole is
toupee but I get it Koppel hit the
artery and Stelter couldn't stop the
bleeding or the laughter Koppel knows
the media operates on two lies that
they'd rather forget one that they're
effusive coverage of Trump didn't help
nominate the guy oh but you did yeah
blubbering fibbers let's not forget
sinan led that charge under the
assumption that hillary had it won
already focused only on Trump knowing
they're profitable obsession would only
hurt Republicans and by their bosses
second in third Holmes whoops too that
somehow Trump had threatened fresh press
freedom
hardly he's now buying those same
executives their fourth in fifth homes
since Trump the press has been feverish
every day's the apocalypse every critic
a fearless hero to CNN especially Trump
is Ebola and the KKK combined it's why
the see in CNN now stands for a cartoon
and not to belabor the point but we know
how easy the press was under Obama even
as he actually targeted journalists
unlike Trump so yeah let's watch that
clip again CNN's ratings would be in the
toilet without Donald Trump you know
that's not true you hope that shows up
on reliable sources but you know it's so
true okay let's go to his point is Ted's
point guy column Ted because we know
each other well it's not just an
obsession it's a profitable one well I
don't understand why brian Stelter
wouldn't just say yeah you bet your life
you're out
so you're right people are so engaged
people want to watch people we can't get
enough of it people want to watch they
don't even want to watch other shows
they only want to talk to us I mean and
we are bringing you the story like why
wouldn't you say that yeah yeah that was
an uncomfortable moment why just spilled
all my water it's okay because you just
wanted you know to express yourself
excited and you're you speak with your
hands but I will say this while these
hands up it could be yeah at least she
didn't flip us the bird or something you
know thinking about it thank you so but
I would I think Stelter was making the
case the Trump attacks the press because
and also that sometimes it's anti Trump
news that drives the media like I think
60 minutes with their stormy interview
got record ratings their highest ratings
in ten years but I don't think there's
any getting away from the idea which is
that Les Moonves in his heyday when he
was still at CBS said guess what Donald
Trump may not be good for America but
he's great for CBS and that means great
for ratings and earnings yeah look he
was the bottom line with this guy
Stelter okay he wants to be the center
of attention and he's sitting there
telling Ted Koppel oh the news business
is more complicated than that Ted you
can talk about stormy Daniels that
wasn't Brian's interview that was
Anderson Cooper's interview and for
Brian to make himself important he's
basically saying I'm a victim I'm a
victim of Trump you know that's a hate
me win at the hunt that's it you know
what it is Ryan what it is are people
tuning in to watch the man that has
allowed you and a lot of other people to
keep their jobs great example of media
bias here though because if the top
Ombudsman at CNN is lying about the
president being good for ratings what
else is he lying about yeah it won't
give Trump credit for the ratings bump
and that's why you see they don't give
him credit for the economy for Isis or
North Korea CNN's ratings have written
high on the Trump bump but there's still
a distant third yeah they're still
getting beat by the Cartoon Network and
house-flipping shows a lot of that stuff
has been caused by Trump
ending them is fake news but they've
also had a lot of self-inflicted wounds
you know they've had to make massive
retractions they have ridiculous
Chiron's you could see the hate dripping
off the faces of some of their anchors
they have had to fire whole classes of
people over there and I've had Democrats
come up to me and say you know what I'm
a Democrat can't stand Trump I actually
hate Trump but you know what I don't
watch CNN because even CNN is too crazy
I'm just gonna say that the difference
with Fox News is that if Hillary had won
our ratings would still be good yeah
that's an interesting pool by the way I
also heard that brian Stelter once threw
ice cubes oh yes